too
pou dou dou
dsc I could have done more when I liked it before the DSC came into force I'm doing it I'm
nervous and stiff Mino ware in Otoichi is the north side effect Don't
say autumn It
's interesting that you can't help yourself at the Tobarihime store  Dojima-san, did you come here to pick me up?
But it was a surprise
.
I don't really care about the Azasan administration
Did you take Central?
No, when I
thought that, what came to my mind was Yukihira Iwaiba and another person,
his face was
Eri Tadokoro, yeah, yeah, I
'm in the middle of guts
.
Is that what your strength is?
What a Kochi store
Tadokoro's approach to vegetables has room for further refinement by Shinomiya no Yado, who also made a name for himself in vegetable cuisine.
Eh
, what I learned from coach Shinomiya is managing
public stores
[applause]